we're now well into the first week of
may it's a beautiful day
so i thought i would shoot out here for
the the monthly update video in which
i'm going to talk about
what went on during april which is a
very busy month as usual
and what we've got coming up in may
which is also pretty packed
before i do that a few quick highlights
three main things
one is that i now have a new position
with the
g cast the global center for advanced
studies and i'll talk about that
when i get to the may section
the half hour hegel videos are are doing
quite well we've actually stepped up
production and we're going to try to get
out six per month because the patreon
campaign
has reached an important milestone and
another important thing i've got a
hangout on air tonight with tom ritchie
another youtube content producer who
who's a high school history professor
and and a
prep master for ap exams we're going to
be talking about
european philosophy so that's coming up
tonight
at nine o'clock eastern standard time
so let's talk about the month of april
april
was like i said a very busy month i only
gave two public speeches during that
time or workshops you might actually
call them
both of which were here in kingston so i
didn't have to travel which is quite
nice
one was in the library series
understanding anger this time
i actually got to talk about the person
who i've done the most research on with
respect to that that's aristotle
i'm currently writing a book about
aristotle's theory of anger i've been
doing that for quite some time
and getting drawn off into a lot of side
projects so
we did that the video for that's been up
for for quite a while
i also did a talk about humility and
whether it's a vice or virtue and we
looked at
six different um philosophers and
theologians two from the ancient times
including aristotle and epictetus
two from the middle ages uh john cassian
really late antiquity john cassian but
we'll call him his middle ages and then
saint anselm
and two from the modern age uh david
hume and mary wollstonecraft
so i did that at the unitarian
universalist
community the catskills and it was great
conversation that we had went on about
twice as long as i expected it to
so that was a lot of fun
videos uh my video production this month
has been largely
confined to half hour hegel videos
i released four of those this month some
critical thinking videos i'm glad to be
getting back into those
uh some of the fallacy videos and i've
also shot some other footage
that i'll be releasing down the line and
uh continuing with releasing the world
views and values videos
this month i concentrated on
who was it rousseau and
we'd already done woolstonecraft um
we'd already done king yeah mainly
rousseau i think
but you know we sort of got caught up on
that
april was a very busy month as far as
courses went i was almost working
uh you know what many of my colleagues
would have as a full-time load
you know three classes in a given term
for three different institutions all of
which are online all of which i produce
all the content for so a lot of work
uh my plano class the existentialism
class finished up in april
uh my marist world views and values
class is getting close to the end so
april was you know the do or die time
for many of them
and we also started the global center
for advanced studies philosophical
foundations class
with a whole you know cohort of students
uh and i've been staying like one step
ahead of them and developing content
sort of like almost laying bridge as
they're going along
so that's been a lot of work now i
mentioned that i have a new position
with the global center for advanced
studies and so i should talk about that
a little bit
i'll talk about what happened during
april and then i'll talk more about the
the
stuff ahead in in the may section so
the global center for advanced studies
is a
entirely online very innovative
very progressive organization that's
devoted to
combating some of the the excesses
and abuses that have occurred in
education because of
what we call neoliberalism you know sort
of like let the market drive things
and the race to the bottom that so many
universities seem to be
involved in and the gcas
their aim is ultimately you know quite
comprehensive they want to be able to
offer
a free or nearly free education based on
sort of an economy of scale and getting
people to
to commit resources to it they're not
anywhere
near that that point yet but they have a
lot of really brilliant researchers
and scholars and they brought me in to
to help with administration because i
have a background in educational
leadership
and assessment of student learning and
curriculum design and i am
also a you know working philosopher as
well
so um at first they put me into the
position
of the director the the acting director
of the institute of critical philosophy
but now there's been a decision made to
actually
create a new institute that i am now the
head of i'm the director of the
institute of humanities and social
sciences
uh what else i carried out some writing
projects i got some work done on writing
on anselm tidying up some papers
that i i long ago wrote and and which
need to go
out i started some work on gabriel
marcel
somebody who i have translated but who i
haven't written
articles on previously but the gabriel
marcel society asked me if i would write
a paper i promised to do it some months
back
and i'm now actually getting to the
outlining stage
so that that's good i also did some some
writing projects on the stoics as well
uh in part because i'm preparing for my
anger
discussion coming up this month and i
got to do a bit of blogging not so much
as i would have liked some of the blogs
are still
laying a bit fallow but i did write
quite a bit in the
half hour hegel blog at least so
i should also talk about the the half
hour hegel project
so um you know i started the patreon
campaign for half hour hegel
back in late february and
um you know it took a little while to
get some traction but it's now
getting quite a few people who want to
be involved with it in part because
they're starting to see the
rewards of it coming out i offer a free
uh question and answer period by by
google hangout once per month
to all of the patrons um they get some
other
you know goodies as well depending on
what scale they get into it at
and um you know some of the patrons have
actually started taking advantage of the
tutorial sessions that i i provide as
one of the perks for
for a certain level so i've been doing a
lot of hegel discussion which is great
i've been shooting videos the editing
takes quite a while so there's a lot of
work on the back end for me before i
release them
and i've been concentrating on that this
month if you're interested in the half
hour hegel project
you know there's a link down in the
description and uh
you know whether you're interested in
hegel or not this is a highly innovative
digital resource never been done before
really
that that i'm i'm working out and which
i'm going to be involved in for at least
the next three years
so if you want to contribute to support
something like that by all means
i'd love to have you with it what else
in april
did a bit of consulting work i also did
some some tutorial sessions you can see
the uh
the new information about the tutorial
sessions on the reason io.com website
if you go there and i also engaged in
some philosophical counseling
i've now put in enough time with that
that i'm
actually um you know starting to to
think about writing something
not so much about my clients but about
um
some of the theory involved in it and
some of the resources that i'm using
so that's what happened in april
let's talk now about the month of may so
i have two events coming up and they're
coming up very soon
one is tonight if this gets uploaded in
time
hopefully it will i'm going to try to
turn this around as quickly as possible
there is a hangout on air free for
anybody who wants to get involved or you
can ask me questions about
modern european philosophy including
hegel related stuff
it'll be um tom richie's uh google
hangout
he does this uh for some of his viewers
he's a guy who's got a channel
kind of similar to mine and then he does
a lot of great videos about
um history of ideas he's focused on on
history primarily
whereas i'm in philosophy but he's
somebody who i very much enjoy
partnering with
because he and i have a lot of similar
intuitions about the nature of ideas and
grand historical developments
and you know he he's a he's a cool guy
so you should check him out
i'm also doing a talk on anger this
weekend
uh may 9th at the kingston public
library it's in that understanding anger
series
this one will actually be on the stoics
and so i'm going to talk about the early
stoics and their views on emotion
and then we'll talk about senecas on
anger he wrote a whole book about anger
epictetus and marcus aurelius
and as usual i'll be posting a video of
that talk later on
i might be doing a hangout later this
month with tom richie specifically
on hegel and hegel's role in history but
that hasn't been
solidified yet so so we don't know if
that's coming up i should also mention
that you know this is looking a little
bit further ahead but one of the things
i'm getting ready for
is during the month of june
the first half of the month i'm actually
going to be
up in new hampshire at the institute for
saint anselm studies
doing a research fellowship helping the
the institute out with some
some materials and also doing some
research
of my own of course and then that'll be
capped by the metaphysics colloquium
which they have every year
at the institute for saint anselm
studies great time for me because i get
to reconnect with
some old colleagues and i get to talk
about ancient and medieval and modern
philosophy
with people who really know their their
stuff you know it's one of those sort of
things that's
very important to have is pure
interaction
um what else we got going on i can
actually say for for once that i have no
courses starting in may as a matter of
fact the
marist class will be wrapping up uh
shortly you know by by
next week the uh
plano class is of course finished the
the global center for advanced studies
philosophical foundations class will end
at the
the end of may but just because i don't
have classes coming out doesn't mean i'm
not actually putting in a lot of work
with classes
because these also like videos take a
lot of designing
on the the back end before you even come
to the class so i have to do a lot of
work
in generating resources and writing
lessons and structuring things
so that's what i'm actually doing i'm
prepping for classes for later in the
summer
and for the fall that will be um marist
apparently and global center for
advanced studies
um videos we're gonna have a lot of cool
video content coming out this month i'm
gonna release six
half hour hegel videos because now we've
passed this milestone
at a certain level of support i told my
patreon supporters
that i would step up the production to
six videos a month and so
i'm a man of my word that's what i'm
going to do
just hoping that we don't reach the
eight videos per month too
too soon because that's a lot of work um
got some world views and values videos
out
uh that are all focused on marks those
are the end of the
this sequence of world views and values
but i will be shooting some more of
those for
an extended version of the class that
will be coming up in in the fall
i'm going to be shooting a lot more
critical thinking videos and releasing
those so expect to see some fallacy
videos
i don't know that we'll get through all
the fallacies through the month of may
but maybe by the end of june we will
i'm going to do because people have been
asking for it when are you going to do
another
self-directed study video i'll release
the next self-directed
study video once i've created it and it
will be on plato and i think i'm going
to focus it
on plato's discussions of of love
and friendship so we're talking about
delicious the symposium and the phaedrus
and so i'll release a video about how
you can carry out self-study about that
and i am thinking about you know down
the line writing an e-book
that would accompany these and sort of
curate the videos and give you
diagrams and study questions and all
that sort of
sort of stuff you know that i could
offer for you know like a i don't know a
minimal price of
like two bucks or three bucks or
something like that but that
that requires me to find the time in
order to to make that happen
with the global center for advanced
studies
now in my new position what i'm
effectively been tasked with
is building an undergraduate program
the gcas institutes that are currently
in place and there's there's seven of
them right now
you know an institute for psychoanalysis
and institute for political economy and
institute for critical philosophy
those are graduate level institutes and
oh you know undergraduate teaching
requires something quite
different uh in in a lot of respects
it takes a lot more work to do
undergraduate teaching believe it or not
than it does to
do graduate level teaching because
undergraduate level teaching
you have to provide a lot more resources
a lot more structure
you need to make sure that you know
we're
thinking about student learning outcomes
and how those tie in with assignments
and how we eventually you know report
this to somebody to show that real
education is taking place that's what's
called assessment
and so i'm the person who's being tasked
with with
attending to all those details but i'm
also the person who's going to be
focusing
on recruiting faculty on scheduling
classes
on developing the curriculum now what's
really cool about this is
gcast doesn't want to do just the same
thing as other
online institutions uh you know why
why even bother doing that we have the
chance to sort of rethink what it what a
university education should be like
for the 21st century and to get away
from the the stupid cliches
that that inhabits so much of the
thinking about it you know they've got
to be computer literate well
it's fine to be computer literate but
that's just you know like a baseline
skill
what about actually being able to
incorporate
thoughts from the entire history of
ideas
that we have as a intellectual heritage
and make sense out of our situations
today with that
that takes a lot more thinking about how
that could happen
and so i i that's that's what my task is
um
fortunately it can be broken down into a
lot of subtests
that's that's what i'm focusing on right
now is is some of the
groundwork you could say but i'll give
you updates about that as we as we go on
i'm doing some more writing projects as
well i'm writing
uh that article on gabriel marcel on the
christian philosophy debates i'm
i'm i've got a paper on aristotle and
anger
that was presented at the cicerone
society back in march that i i need to
expand
and finish up you know finish all the
rough edges in it add in some footnotes
and then submit to their journal i am
working on a paper on thomas aquinas
views on anger
and leadership for a conference coming
up
in june and i want to get that one you
know solidly
you know i want to get everything in
place for that at least conference paper
ready not necessarily publication ready
but
conference paper ready and i'm going to
be doing more blogging this month
as a matter of fact tonight you can you
can hopefully see
an entry in the heavy metal philosopher
i've got
something i've been working on for the
virtue ethics digest which i haven't
contributed to for a while
orexis dia noeticae you know there's
some things i'm going to put in there as
well having to do with education and
adjunct sandler's existentialism updates
got to do some updates haven't done
those for a while
and of course the half hour hegel blog
now there's also the
reason i owe blog itself if you want to
just follow you know what i'm what i'm
doing and important events that are
coming up i put little blurbs about them
in there
but my main blogs are these these other
five blogs where i
i you know get my my thoughts out on on
the screen
um what else i might be doing a little
bit more consulting work that that's
that still uh remains to be seen
about this month it has to do with
certain agreements that uh
i'm not going to discuss in here i'm
hoping that i'll get some some more
tutorial sessions booked
so if you're interested in tutorial
sessions
you can see the information about that
on the reasonio.com website
and i have quite a few sessions for
philosophical counseling already booked
but i do still have openings so if you
think that you are the kind of person
who might benefit from philosophical
counseling
um you're you're certainly welcome to to
you know shoot me an email at greg at
reason i owe and
and i'll send you the documents about it
i haven't built out that part of the
reason i owe website yet but
but i will be doing that this month as
well so that all the information will be
there and
people can get a solid idea about what
philosophical counseling is
i might even produce a video about it if
i if i find myself with any
you know extra spare time which is
probably not that likely
in any case that's all the stuff that's
coming up in may so
uh i hope that you'll you know tune in
to some of it or
you know benefit from some of it and
otherwise have a good month